[music]
>> Amazing. Welcome everyone.
Welcome to Google IO. Welcome to what's
new in Google AI and welcome to the
first sessions of the day after the
keynotes. Is everybody really excited?
>> Woo!
>> Amazing. So, I am so grateful to be here
today with my colleague Amar. My name is
Paige. I'm the engineering lead for a
developer relations team at Google
DeepMind. And Amar
>> I lead product and design on AI Studio.
>> Very cool. And today we're going to be
attempting to condense into 45 minutes
an overview of everything that we've
been doing at Google in the AI space.
It's going to be really hard.
But the good news is that for the rest
of today and the rest of tomorrow and
further on in the week, we have a whole
bunch of other talks that are intended
to be deep dives for some of the things
that we'll just be touching on lightly
today.
So, I don't think it's a secret that
we've been shipping at a pretty
relentless
>> An insane amount of pace. I think if you
just look at 2024 when we had the 1.5
series of models, we're just cracking
the nut on multi-modality and look where
we are now.
>> Exactly. And today we released Gemini
3.5 Flash, which we'll be talking about
in a second.
But it's everything from frontier models
to open models and more.
Our Gemini 3 model lineup has expanded
pretty significantly both today and over
the course of the last couple of months.
We've got Gemini 3.5 Pro, which is still
kind of our our best and brightest model
to use
for complex problems. 3.5 Flash for kind
of performance and speed and cost. This
is also the Flash series is the default
in AI Studio's build, right?
>> Yeah, we use 3.5 Flash as our default
model for building apps and it's
incredibly capable. In fact, the AI
Studio mobile app that'll be coming out
in a few weeks,
a bunch of it was built with 3.5 flash.
So, it's just been amazing to see it
trip across both Android and iOS.
>> Amazing. And then also 3.1 flashlight,
which is really great for kind of these
these use cases that require low
latency, but can also save you a lot of
costs, which is pretty cool. Um, it's
not just us using Gemini 3. We are
blessed to have a whole bunch of
customers across the industry. Um,
Databricks, GitHub, Harvey, um, Warp,
and a whole bunch more that have Gemini
3 running in production. Um, and Gemini
is really remarkable in the industry
because it's great at understanding all
of these many different modalities, um,
text and image and audio and video and
code, um, but it can also output
multiple modalities.
>> Yeah, I think one of my favorite things
is because it understands so many
modalities, when you're building,
especially when you're building apps,
um, I upload a video of an animation,
and it can understand the frames of that
animation and then recreate that in
code. And so, video understanding just
unlocks a whole new set of use cases,
uh, and I mean, so does all the other
modalities.
>> Yep. And the screenshots that you can
take and use to inform the front-end
design for some of Build's features are
really, really powerful tools as well.
Um, our generative media models are kind
of testaments to this fact, um, that
we're able to output video, um, we can
output audio. We have some pretty
exciting text-to-speech models and
Gemini live models, um, and then also
our live API, which we'll demo in just a
second, gives you real-time interactions
with the, uh, with Gemini itself. Um,
and today,
uh, you know, we've talked a lot about
nano banana, um, aka Gemini 3.1 flash
image,
um, which gives you high-fidelity visual
assets. Um, we've got nano banana 2,
which you can try yourself in AI Studio.
And today we've basically released Nano
Banana for video.
>> [laughter]
>> Gemini only Omni Flash, which allows you
to create anything from any input
starting with video.
>> Starting with video and I think the
other thing is editing is such a tedious
task, especially getting the little
details right. And the fact that we have
Nano Banana style editing for video now
is like super exciting and in the API
soon, so that'll be really fun to build
with as well.
>> 100% and if you haven't had a chance to
try it yet, there's a really nice AI
demo garden in the back of this
building. If you're on site,
that should allow you to create a
commercial starring yourself using using
Omni. It's called Omni Marshall.
Be patient if there's a line.
>> [laughter]
>> But it's a lot of fun to try.
If you're curious about generative
media, make sure to go to this session.
Build creative apps with Gen Media Suite
later this week
with a couple of a couple of folks from
our team
and they will be able to answer all of
your questions.
All of these models are stitched
together and anti-gravity as kind of
like the IDE that powers these
experiences. We're all using
anti-gravity pretty heavily at Google
internally.
>> Every day.
>> Every single day to check in to check in
code, to help review code, to kind of
design these new experiences. And we're
also using AI Studio
for everything from product ideation to
building apps to rapid prototyping.
Because it is the fastest path from
prompt to apps, but I really hate
slides.
>> Me too. I hate slides.
>> Okay, so we both hate slides. It's much
more fun to show these things in action.
So let's go ahead and go to some demos
so you can actually see these tools and
we'll see how well the Wi-Fi holds up.
Excellent.
>> Okay, back in the playground.
>> Back in the playground.
>> So, for those who are not familiar, this
is the AI Studio playground and
homepage. Here, you can experiment with
all of DeepMind's latest models. Uh you
can tweak all the parameters to see
what's what they're capable of. It's an
amazing way to just get a sense of all
the capabilities. And uh you can just
take uh code snippets from here and go
and build apps with them as well. But
Paige, you want to kick it off with a
demo?
>> Yeah, absolutely. I'm going to zoom in a
little bit so uh so we can see, and then
also show you how you can uh kind of
select different media types in AI
Studio if you haven't seen this before.
Um you can add files from Drive, you can
upload files, record audio, camera, um
add YouTube videos, um and you can also
select some sample media. So, if I was
to select um this video, add it to the
prompt, um we've got Gemini 3.1
flashlight pulled up, which is again
kind of our most
>> Cops optimized model. You can say
>> It should be pretty fast. Um you can say
create a table with timestamps
um for all of the dinosaurs you see in
this video. Um make sure to include a
fun fact about each dinosaur. Um hit uh
hit run. Um and we can see the number of
tokens that's pulled from this
5-minute-ish long video, it's around
31,000.
Um
>> Fast.
>> Very fast. We've got a table with the
dinosaur name, the timestamps, the fun
fact. And then if I hover over this
token consumption, you can see that it
took about a penny and a half in order
to do all that work. Um which is pretty
wild. And and then, just like Amar said,
if you click get code, you can see all
of the code that you would need to use
to replicate whatever you just did,
including search as a one-liner for a
tool call, um this thinking config, and
then the model selection that we have
here up at the top. Um so that is
playground in a nutshell. Um and it
allows you to experiment not just with
our Gemini family of models, but also
things like uh like Nano Banana and some
of the other video generation models
that we have along the way.
Um we also talked a little bit about
Gemini Live.
>> this one.
>> Yes. And so Gemini Live gives you the
opportunity to have a real-time
conversation with the model, um but also
share multimodal content. It's been
around for a while, um but it's really
really cool to think about building into
your apps. Um so if I click share
screen,
it's going to ask me to select a Chrome
tab. I'm going to go ahead and select
that dinosaur table that we just created
previously, though you could select any
app or any tab. Um I'm going to go back
to uh Google AI Studio, and I'm going to
say,
"Hey there, Gemini. Could you tell me
what you see on the screen?"
>> I am looking at the Google AI Studio.
The main part of the screen shows a
table of dinosaurs with timestamps and
fun facts about them. For instance, it
says Ornithomimus was a speedy dinosaur.
Is there anything specific you'd like me
to focus on?
>> Does anybody speak a language other than
English in the room?
>> Arabic?
>> Arabic. Awesome. I also heard Brazilian
Portuguese or Portuguese Portuguese.
>> Ooh.
>> Excellent. [laughter]
What? Chinese? Awesome. So I'm going to
ask uh I'm going to ask uh the model to
repeat what it just said, um but to say
it in Chinese, and then we'll also try
another couple of languages, but you
have to fact-check me, um if that's
okay. Cool.
Hey there, Gemini. Could you repeat what
you just said, but could you tell me in
Chinese, please?
>> Hǎo de. Méi wèntí. Wǒ kàn dào de shì
Google
>> Did it do okay?
>> Excellent.
>> Let's go.
>> Wonderful. Amazing.
>> [applause]
>> Very cool. And then you can also So that
was just kind of asking it to change
languages dynamically within the context
of the conversation. You can also say in
the system instructions, only respond to
the user in Brazilian Portuguese.
If I have a person who will fact-check
me in the audience for Brazilian
Portuguese, yeah, excellent. And then
I'm going to turn on grounding with
Google Search and we are going to ask
Gemini a question as well. So.
Hey there, Gemini. Can you tell me what
you see? Can you tell me what you see?
>> [snorts]
>> It was right. Okay.
Cool, cool. Amazing. And then since it's
got grounding with Google Search, I
could also say,
"Hey there, Gemini. Could you tell me
what the weather is like today in
Mountain View, California?"
Was that also correct? Yep. Excellent.
And you can also see the sources that it
pulled in to help ground its outputs.
And just like before, you can click get
code and see everything that you would
need in order to replicate the
experiment that we just tried.
>> That's awesome.
>> Um so this is uh in in Python and
TypeScript and .NET, whatever your
favorite language might be, um both
programmatic or uh computery, and uh AI
Studio is really just a magical place to
get started with all of these things. Um
but it's not just the playground.
>> Not just the playground. Yeah, there's a
lot more.
>> You want to show us builds and what
you've all been cooking there?
>> Yeah, so uh if you don't want to click
get code and actually take code and
build in an IDE, we offer a completely
batteries-included building experience,
and that's build mode here. So I'm just
going to click that, and build mode
effectively allows you to prompt any
idea into life, uh and you'll be able to
pick between all the capabilities that
we have to offer. So you can do
text-to-speech, music generation,
databases, and the new thing we've added
that we're super excited about is
building Android apps directly from AI
Studio. And so what I'm really excited
about is you won't have to deal with any
of the setup of Android apps or getting
a simulator or anything like that
working. You'll just be able to prompt
an app to existence. So an idea I had
was around this piano,
but I wanted to do it for this foldable
phone I have over here. Um and so
>> Which is very fancy. How do I get one of
those?
>> Um you know, you just expense one.
>> [laughter]
>> So
So all you have to do is say I want to
make a foldable piano app
for fold phones
where the top half
of the screen is a tutorial,
and the bottom half are piano keys that
I can play.
>> Awesome.
>> And the other thing I'll just show you
is we just left it for a second, and
it'll even give you suggestions that you
can tab into your prompt. And so this
just helps you build out a more complete
prompt. If you don't know where to go,
or if you're just curious about where
the the could take you, which is always
really fun.
>> Yeah, so you can tap your complete your
way into a startup idea.
>> Yeah.
>> what you were telling me?
>> Exactly.
>> Amazing.
>> But, you know, I don't like that idea.
So, I'm going to keep that away for now.
And so, I can go ahead and hit build,
and it'll go and start to build this
idea out.
Um and so, the other thing you'll see is
AI Studio says right here it's
generating a theme. Um and so, what's
happening is while your app is building
on the left, AI Studio is also able to
de- design a bunch of uh design themes
for your app. Um and super fun to just
see the inspiration kind of come through
from the model. So, you can see it's
kind of giving us some interface ideas
on how it's designing the app.
>> Oh, that's pretty.
>> You know, we can choose between a few
different ones. Um even a video tutorial
idea, which is pretty cool.
Um or this elegant dark one, which I
really do like.
>> That is very pretty. I like the pastel
colors.
>> Yeah, super nice. I like the little glow
it added. So, these things help you kind
of, you know, I can hit select this
design and I'll just add that prompt in.
Or I can just skip that and let it build
that first version of the app. Um but
while that builds, I actually did start
this before this demo.
Um so, I do have it here. I'm just going
to refresh this.
Um and then we can go and build that one
as well.
>> And this app is generated natively in
Kotlin, is that right?
>> It's natively in Kotlin. And so, again,
similar prompts. You can see my first
prompt again, build a piano app,
foldable thing. And if I hit code, you
can see all the Kotlin code.
And the other thing you saw earlier was
we said that Antigravity Export is also
in the app.
>> Yeah.
>> You can click export and then take that
over
uh and go from there.
>> And it will also remember all of the
context, all of the history, all of the
kind of back-and-forth that you had in
AI Studio as it brings it into
Antigravity.
>> Exactly. So, the whole conversation kind
of flows through, which is which is
really nice.
But, okay. So, we have this install
button. I'm just going to zoom out for a
sec. Um and it allows you to basically
connect any phone and then install it
via USB. Uh Um, the USB can sometimes be
fiddly on stage, so we're going to try
something.
Um, just going to kill the USB
connection.
And unlock my phone.
Let's see if this works.
>> Amazing.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
Let's see if it installs the latest
version. Allow.
Okay. Seems to be installing.
And then
hopefully any second now on AI Studio we
will see the new build complete.
>> Will install to the device. There it
goes.
>> So it's installed on the device and you
can see I have this piano app now on my
foldable phone.
Um
Yeah.
>> [applause]
>> Amazing.
>> Yeah, and super fun because I think
you're just going to see so many new
developers come through who just wanted
to make apps for their phone or the web
and all they have to do is describe an
AI Studio.
>> Do you want to do you want to start it a
little bit?
>> Should I play it? Yeah. See how it goes.
>> I'm not sure if y'all can hear here, but
it looks like it's popped up on the
screen as well.
>> Yeah.
>> So maybe maybe we could also try in the
Android emulator.
>> Well, the emulator is getting audio
soon.
>> Got you.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, I'm not very good, but this is
what exactly why I need this app.
So yeah, this is coming and then soon
we'll also have Play Store distribution
as well. So you'll be able to just
submit an app from the place to the Play
Store from here
and then you're published to the world.
>> Amazing.
>> Yeah.
Uh, alongside Android development soon
we'll also have the ability to build
Well, actually rolling out today is
Workspace apps as well.
>> Which means you can connect Gmail and
calendar and all of the other Workspace
products into AI Studio. Is that right?
Just through prompting?
>> Just through prompting.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. Do you have an idea?
>> I I have an idea about
um
So, I know that we've been talking about
our meeting invites
and our calendars are a little bit
overwhelmed.
Wasn't there an idea that you had around
sort of calendar roulette?
>> I did. I did. You know, I've already
built that one. Should I show you?
>> Yep, let's see it.
>> It's uh it's a pretty fun one. Um
It's a slightly scary app for those who
might not want to, you know, trust a
model to do this, but I basically was
like, "Hey, just look at my calendar,
find any meeting, and then just delete
it."
>> [laughter]
>> But definitely ask me before you do that
because I I need to check if I can
>> sure it's not a meeting with Logan.
>> And make sure it's not a meeting with
Logan, [laughter] yeah. So, we're just
going to sign in.
Uh a little risky.
And then you can see it's like picked up
some meetings, you know, it's it's got
that, and I can spin it, and then it's
going to go and figure out what meeting
to delete.
>> I love that it's got all of the IO,
keynote, launch cow, all of these
[laughter] things.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and it's automatically used OAuth to
to log you in with your Google account
based on our Firebase integration.
>> Exactly. And so, you can see it even
knows there are 15 events later today.
So, I definitely want to get out of few
of those. I'll be using this app to make
that happen.
>> Excellent. Sounds good to me.
So cool. So So, this is a great overview
of playground and build some of the
newest features in both.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and I think that we're really, really
excited to see what y'all can create
with AI Studio and with all of these
tools.
To access it, all people have to do is
go to ai.dev, right?
>> Yeah, they only they only have to go to
ai.dev. Somebody's telling me to spin
this wheel, and I'm too afraid to see
what it's going to do live. So, we'll
save that for later, you and me.
>> [laughter]
>> Cool, cool, cool. Well, let's go back.
So, this is a brief taste of all of the
things that we've been building in the
AI Studio team. Um if you're curious
about AI Studio, you're in luck because
the next section is all about AI Studio
and to gravity um and how you can
incorporate those workflows into your
own projects.
Um we've also released something called
the interactions API within AI Studio.
So you can create an API key and get
started with agents um and build new
agentic experiments with the uh with the
Gemini APIs. If you're curious about
that, about our managed agent platform,
um we talked a little bit about it in
the keynotes earlier this morning. But
>> it's basically giving you the ability to
uh that same vibe coding style that you
just saw where you can describe in
natural language anything. Uh it will
generate a managed agent for you
connecting to services and running on a
cloud VM.
>> Yeah. And it's the anti-gravity agent
powering all of it, which is really
awesome. So you have the exact same
power and capabilities working in an
environment with just one API call.
>> Amazing. Uh and if you're curious about
that, um make sure to go see the build
agents with Gemini API session with
Philip and Thor um later this week. Uh
they'll also be touching a little bit
around the Gemini Live API, around our
text-to-speech models, and all of the
things that you can do with those.
Um
we've not only been shipping frontier
models.
>> Right.
>> And something that's really near and
dear to my heart is open models.
>> Open models, open-source models. And I
think to see how far Gemma 4 has come uh
and what's possible with it. And
especially the demos we've been seeing
this week on how it's running on device
and pulling off some incredible things.
>> Absolutely. And Gemma 4 is available to
test out in the playground in AI Studio
as well for folks who want to get
started. An under known fact, I think,
is that you get a non-zero number of uh
Gemma calls on the the APIs for free. Um
so if you wanted to incorporate it into
your app, it's great at understanding
video, audio,
images, text, code, kind of all of the
above.
And you can kind of compare and contrast
with the Gemini models and other models
that you might have incorporated into
your apps as well.
We've got a huge huge Gemma 4 community
that's pulling
pulling down many many downloads across
across the world. Gemma supports over
140 different languages. You can find it
today on Hugging Face. It has a 256,000
token context window.
And if you want to learn more about the
Gemma open model family, make sure to
check out the session with Olivier, Gus,
and Ian
also later this week. We've also been
really blessed to have strong
partnerships with the Unsloth community,
with Llama,
and many many others like Kaggle
to bring these Gemma models into the
world. And it's it's been
you know, only the beginning for what's
possible with Gemma 4.
So, this is also for folks who haven't
tried running models at the edge before.
Have actually I'm really curious. How
many folks have used open models before
or using them in your projects?
Few hands. If not, definitely make sure
to try out the Google AI Edge Gallery.
It's a great way to bring down costs for
your projects, especially as the models
that you can use on mobile devices, on
laptops are getting more and more
powerful.
>> Yeah, I especially love the offline
usage because I was on a plane ride for
about 8 hours and Gemma 4 by coding with
it and it actually worked really well.
>> Amazing.
>> So, it's amazing to see that all run
locally.
>> Yep. And Gemma 4 can run on your laptop.
Gemma 2 can even run on a mobile device.
So, I think we've added it to the Pixel
10 Um, so that it can power some of the
on device agentic use cases that that
folks might want on on Android and on
Pixel devices.
And again, if you're curious about on
device ML, um, Sachin and Aaron will
tell you all about it later this week,
too.
Um,
Google is kind of special though and the
in the sense that we aren't just a
company that has, uh, you know, models
that are available via REST APIs, models
that are available to download and to
fine-tune and to use for your projects.
We also have our open-source TPU
software stack.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, so everything from inference to
post-training, pre-training, and model
building, um, kind of the usual suspects
like vLLM, um, for TPU inference, um,
for both JAX and PyTorch, T5X for
post-training with RL and agentic
workflows, MAX Text, um, and then also
JAX and Torch TPU, um, for making TPUs
run really, really fast and in a really
performant way. Um, it's been amazing to
see how much JAX has been able to push
the boundaries for every single model
that we build at Google. Um, and our
DeepMind team is exclusively using JAX
to build out all of its all of its
models and infrastructure.
And if you're curious about that, uh,
make sure to go to Josh, uh, Josh's
session, um, later this week where he'll
be talking about how you can scale AI,
um, with the TPU software stack.
Uh, this full stack approach is really
unique. Um, everything from AI
infrastructure to data, to models, to
our AI platform on Cloud, um, to things
like agents and apps via Gemini Spark,
via AI Studio, um, and more. And also
all of this being done in a very secure
way. Um, I was really excited to see the
SynthID announcements earlier today.
>> the partners. Yeah.
>> Yeah, partnering with, uh, even, uh, you
know, other model service providers
across the industry, um, and attempting
to do this in a way that really,
um, is kind of putting safety and
responsibility at
>> I think we'll need to give the calendar
alert app to everybody here to clear
their schedule for all these sessions,
yeah.
>> This is true.
>> [laughter]
>> Amazing. So, what's next? Like, I guess
that's the the general question. Like,
>> Always.
>> given given all of these things that
exist today, that were announced today,
this overwhelming onslaught of AI
that's, uh, even just from Google and
the DeepMind team that's being released
into the world, um, what are you most
excited about that's coming next?
>> Well, I love all the robotic stuff. It's
always super exciting. I know you love
the robots, too.
>> I really, really love the robotic stuff.
Um, especially especially since because
of the Gemini APIs, they can be put
pretty much anywhere.
>> On anywhere, but
>> Any any device that can call a REST API
is capable of using, uh, using our
robotics.
>> Yeah, and there was a great demo of
Reachy Mini from Hugging Face, and it
was using Gemini robotics, uh, and
that's open source as well, the that
project.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, but yeah, we recently announced
Gemini robotics 1.6,
um, and it's just, uh, incredible to see
that out in the wild now.
>> Yeah, and I I think it's also, uh,
really powerful in the sense that, you
know, you mentioned the Reachy Mini,
>> Yeah.
>> there's also a beautiful open-source
project from Stanford called the Pupper,
uh, which is used for their CS
curriculum. It, uh, has a Raspberry Pi
powering it behind the scenes, all of
the parts are 3D printed, um, but since
it's just kind of using this commodity
hardware, it can call the Gemini Live
API, use Gemini robotics ER to kind of
manipulate this little robotic dog, and
you can ask it to do anything from like
follow me, and it will follow you around
the stage.
>> Very cool.
>> Yeah, or to like go and fetch that ball.
>> training is needed for that one?
>> Mostly, uh, so it's not any training
required. It's, uh, you know, batteries
included, like the the first dog that
you do not have to train.
>> Yeah.
>> But the, uh, but you just have a
conversation with Pupper and it's
capable of having a
having kind of this dynamic uh interop
with you across a broad spectrum of use
cases.
>> That's awesome.
>> Yeah.
In addition to that, we also have our
world model family, um Genie 3, which
was touched on a little bit today in the
keynote.
>> Yeah, part of the Omni model and that
gives it the understanding of the
physics of the world and how things
actually work. Uh and that's why you see
the video coherence is so good cuz it
actually understands how things actually
need to work in the real world.
>> Absolutely. And you can describe any
world that you would like to experience
and then navigate around it using your
arrow keys in order to create uh create
a short video. So, as an example, um
this is a prompt that uh you know, a
tranquil waterfall cliff area featuring
dynamic water physics. And then a
character, which is a high-speed paper
airplane. And so, you can see similar to
what Omar was just mentioning, the
physics of the airplane as it's kind of
interacting with some of the splashes,
um the physics of the currents in the
river, how this is moving and banking.
>> Um and then even the reflections of the
light on on the water.
>> It's so so nice. Could you play it
again, please?
Awesome, thank you. And so, you can see
even the splashes um kind of going down
in the water as it jumps off the
waterfall. Um so, I strongly strongly
encourage you all to play around with
Genie 3. It's available today if you
have a Google AI Ultra subscription, um
in addition to many, many of the other
products that were featured in the
keynotes this morning.
Awesome.
And then
So, I think the the most important thing
to call out is that we're building kind
of the first generation of tools for
people who are AI native. Um and who
really don't have to ask for permission
in order to create anything that they've
been imagining.
>> I keep telling people all you literally
have to do is just go to that prompt box
and describe your idea. And people have
asked me, you know, what what is the tip
you have or something for folks. And I
usually just go in assuming that the
idea I have is going to work.
>> Yep.
>> Uh and you'll realize how far you can
actually push the model uh to make your
idea very real. And if it doesn't work
in this iteration, I guarantee you
another model iteration and you'll be
able to make that idea come to life.
>> Yep. And since we've been adding
databases to AI Studio, authentication,
um even things like these workspace
integrations, it really does feel like
you can go very, very far without ever
needing to leave the browser and popping
into an IDE.
>> Yeah. And soon on your phone, too, with
the AI Studio mobile app coming very
soon.
>> Amazing. And the uh like I can't wait
for this world where I'm just walking
around, describe an idea that I have,
and then by the time I get home, it's
already landed in my inbox.
>> You're just a few weeks away from that.
>> Very cool. Amazing. So, for anyone who
is uh curious, excited, who wants to try
out and test more, wants to try our
models,
um
uh make sure to go to ais.studio/build.
Um and we also just want to say thank
you so much for coming to IO this year,
for your energy, for your excitement.
>> Yeah.
>> Um we really appreciate y'all
uh and can't wait to see what you build.
>> [applause]
>> Yeah.
>> Yep.